thank you
this is Sky News at 10 our top story I'm
struggling to here but this is my normal
life
the migrants living and working in the
shadows and those ditching their Asylum
claims as the government ramps up its
rhetoric
striking back after a talk with his boss
defiant Gary lineker insists he'll be
back on our screens this weekend we have
a chat with you anything about the Tweet
Gary do you regret sending the tweet at
all
reports several people have been killed
in the German city of Hamburg as police
confirm an operation is underway
hs2 Rel links to crew and Manchester are
delayed by two years as local businesses
count the cost
I knew she was gone a court hears at the
moment nine-year-old Olivia Pratt
corbell's mother discovered the bullet
wound in her chest
and the Arctic blast delaying spring
with strong winds and 40 centimeters of
snow predicted for some
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
they are the Disappeared migrants who
arrived in the UK illegally but who've
intentionally abandoned their Asylum
claims and chosen to go underground
they're trapped between people
traffickers and a government intent on
pushing international law to its limits
to stop people like them coming to the
UK until now their voices have been
missing from the debate over new
proposals outlined this week Sky News
has heard the fears of deportation and
seen firsthand what it's really like to
live and work in the shadows our
communities correspondent Lisa Holland
has tonight's first report
to meet three men who came to the UK to
seek Asylum they don't want us to know
where they're staying so you've all gone
underground all disappeared yeah living
outside of society
in a week which has seen the government
ratchet up its strategy to stop people
entering the country illegally we can
reveal threats to deport Asylum Seekers
to Rwanda were already driving those
here into hiding
dravid is from India and flew to the UK
using fake documents I don't want to
like attend the home office to proceed
my claim you don't want to risk it no I
don't want to risk it so what are you
afraid of that if you report in that
they'll detain you they may be like
detain me and they can send me to Rwanda
it means
Authority
clarifies them I am ready nervous and
suffering and I quoted I don't know
I had sent Andrew Benson say their
tamils who
you shouldn't and torture in Sri Lanka
they cross the channel by small boat
after risking their lives to get here
they're also now ditching their Asylum
claims I came to three Adam so what
second damage tried three times the
second time supposed to be water you
know like you're capsized yeah he's
pushed me out of water then I'm swimming
then inside
Third Time Lucky but did you think that
your life here would be like it is now
on the Run not now I'm not like it
but going into hiding can make it
difficult to access some medical care
and leaving the hotel accommodation
provided by the government for Asylum
Seekers whilst their claims are being
processed everyone that we've spoken to
says they're only really able to exist
outside of the system because they're
offered somewhere to live or given cash
in hand work by people they know within
their own community
Going Underground here's a glimpse into
the future tomorrow is the day to taking
all cardboards
Kanika sabbathy is paid cash in hand by
other Sri Lankans to do
this work
he came to the UK nearly 20 years ago
and also says he fled persecution he's
lived in this garage for five years
since his Asylum claim failed
he's very aware the home office is
stepping up raids on undocumented
migrants living illegally like him
it's a miserable and lonely existence
so for you this is a normal life this is
my local Idol I don't know what is the
difference because I'm struggling to
hear but this is my normal life do you
know a lot of people who live like you
live yeah I have one or two friends they
also look like that sometimes they're
sleeping on the on the road at least I
got something that's what I think
it's estimated that could be around a
million migrants living illegally in
Britain fueling the cash in hand economy
another problem for a government
desperately trying to stop anyone else
from joining its broken Asylum system
Lisa Holland Sky News
well that's the evidence that Asylum
Seekers already here are being driven
Underground key to deterring others from
arriving in small boats will be securing
an agreement with France prime minister
Rishi Suna meets the French President
Emmanuel macron in Paris tomorrow in an
attempt to do just that let's go to
Downing Street now and our chief
political correspondent John Craig and
John the Prime Minister will be Keen to
deepen Corporation will with Emmanuel
macron what exactly will he be offering
and what could success look like
well top of the prime minister's agenda
obviously is tackling the small boats
crisis in the channel he wants a deal
with President macron whereby the French
will take back the migrants who are
deported from the UK a returns policy as
it's known uh he also wants more help
from the French in patrolling those
beaches in France and basically beefing
up security he's prepared to pay the
French more money the government's
already handed over millions many Tory
MPS say they're not getting value for
money but the signs are that President
macron may say look that is a British
domestic issue and also the question of
returning people from the UK to the
continent of Europe is a matter for the
European Union not just for France so he
may not get the successful deal that he
hopes for the French of course that's
not top of their agenda they want to
talk about defense cooperation the war
in Ukraine and other international
issues science and so on energy security
and so on this is the first of these
Summits for five years they used to be
almost annual but of course after brexit
relations between the UK and France have
deteriorated
um Boris Johnson famously said Donnie
Moi and break to the French Liz truss
said the jury was out on whether
president macron was a friend or Foe but
so far Mr sunak's relations with the
president have been much improved on
previous years and he will be hoping
that at this Summit he can make the on
taunt more cordial
John thank you
I want to bring you some breaking news
now from the German city of Hamburg
where there are reports that several
people have been killed in a shooting
Let's cross that to our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins who's in
Berlin for research what more can you
tell us Siobhan
good evening yes this is still very new
information coming in we have had some
updates though on social media from
Hamburg police I'm going to read them to
you we understand that this shooting
seems to have happened at around nine
o'clock this evening in Hamburg that's
according to DPA news agency now the
police are saying according to initial
findings shot were fired in a church in
a street in Deal Burger in the district
of gross bostal which is in Hamburg
several people were seriously injured
they're saying some even fatally they
are on the scene there's a large
contingent of them there and they say
more information will follow now they're
also saying at the moment there is no
clear information about the motive
Behind These shootings this is a very
active and moving investigation at the
moment there are unconfirmed reports in
local media that as many as six people
could have been killed many more injured
but as they say at the moment none of
that officially confirmed by the police
what we do know from the police is that
they are on the scene in a large
contingent responding to this report of
shootings in a church in Hamburg okay
Siobhan will be back to you for further
updates should they come in thank you
now returning to the government match of
the day host Gary lineker has been one
of the most prominent critics of the
government's migration plans his
accusation that ministers use language
not dissimilar to that used by Germany
in the 1930s has prompted a row over BBC
impartiality but today despite calls for
him to resign or be sacked the former
footballer insisted he would be
presenting the goals this Saturday Ashna
horanag reports
future of the BBC's highest paid
presenter is called into question for
being vocal Gary lineker says he stands
by his views have you heard from the BBC
Gary
what does the director General say
anything to you
um yeah as he said he said well we have
a chat we chat often anything about the
Tweet Gary do you regret sending the
tweet at all
clearly conversations so far working in
lilica's favor with him remaining on air
this weekend but The Rao is rumbling on
the Home Secretary has branded his
comments offensive and that they push
the boundaries of freedom of speech to
kind of throw throw out uh those kind of
flippant analogies diminishes it
diminishes the unspeakable tragedy that
millions of people went through working
here in any capacity comes with
guidelines staff are bound by due
impartiality even if they don't work in
news or current affairs the corporation
has a difficult task get rid of one of
the most popular faces on the BBC or
risk making a mockery of those
guidelines one former BBC editorial
director says reaching a compromise will
be difficult I don't think it merits
suspending Gary right now however it
would have to be done his return to
match the day on the basis of the
complaints process was underway and
there would be a resolution to it and
that's why at the moment it's rather
murky what's going on in BBC Salford and
BBC London but there will be all sorts
of machinations going on about how
Saturday works more importantly how the
future conduct of all presenters is
dealt with by the BBC there's Confidence
from one of the corporation's most
popular Stars after this accusation in
the Commons labor are borrowing from the
Gary lineker Playbook they are party of
gold hangers and the occasional
left-wing Striker there was yet more
Defiance I'm just happy to have been
better in the six yard box than you are
at the dispatch box he tweeted
with his spot on the schedule and the
BBC's position unchanged lilica for now
seems Resolute he's going nowhere Ashton
harinag Sky News
its budget has already more than doubled
it's been beset by delay after delay and
today the transport secretary confirmed
the high-speed 2 Rail Link would not be
completed until Beyond 2040 that's 30
years after it was first announced
connections from Birmingham to crew and
Manchester woman I'll be pushed back by
two years because of soaring inflation
our political correspondent Liz bate has
been hearing about the likely impact on
local economies the first trains will
run in 2026. in just over a decade's
time we'll have Journeys from hearing
crew people are going to see these
improvements soon in this decade rather
than having to wait till the likes of
2040s to to see it deliver
after over a decade of broken promises
High Speed 2 has been delayed yet again
with the government announcing that
affordability pressures mean more hold
ups and cutbacks that will impact mostly
on phase two from Birmingham through
Crewe to Manchester
for This Crew business finding out that
the town's High-Speed Rail connection
will be subject to a two-year delay
taking the completion date to 2036 has
come as a blow clearly it's
disappointing the local economy is is
being built on the back of hs2 coming to
crew obviously crew Nan twitch the towns
and villages in the surrounding area are
all looking for that boost to the
economy and any delay obviously means
that that's a delay for the local
economy and the infrastructure more
criticism from those who have long
campaigned to improve transport links
across the north the poor productivity
issues in the north of England are
directly correlated to the poor
transport that made me late for this
interview happens all the time
in the capital the central London Hub in
Houston will also take years longer than
planned it's to keep costs down on a
project whose budget has already
ballooned from 33 billion pounds to over
70 billion pounds its end date now
Beyond 2040.
30 years since it was first announced
and some conservative MPS are calling on
the government to cut their losses we
don't need to spend this money we could
improve the railways we've got with
better signaling with improvements that
gets more trains on the west coast
Mainline for example let's just say
sorry we made a mistake
save that money on a point of order Mr
deputy
accused of burying the news in a written
statement the deputy speaker agreed with
labor that a minister must come to the
house to face questions there has to be
an expectation that members will have
the earliest opportunity to question
ministers on this statement this tees up
a Commons Clash next week that could
further derail what has long been one of
the UK's most divisive transport
projects Liz Bates Sky News Westminster
I knew she had gone the evidence heard
in court today from the mother of
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt colbell who
died after being shot in her home Cheryl
Corbell also described the moment she
lifted her daughter's clothes to
discover she'd been shot in the chest
Thomas Cashman who's accused of the
killing appeared to wipe away tears in
the dock as our chief north of England
correspondent Greg myland reports
Thomas Cashman was brought to court to
hear in her own words the mother of the
child he's accused of murdering describe
what happened that night
the video of a police interview with
Cheryl Corbell recorded a week after the
shooting last August was played to the
jury in it she talks about the moment
Olivia Pratt Corbell was shot and the
moment she learned that her daughter had
died in the video her arm is still
bandaged from her own injuries that
night she said she realized there'd been
a shooting outside and that someone was
trying to get inside I was screaming for
them to go away she said I heard a
gunshot and felt it hit my hand she said
I couldn't keep the door shut and then
she heard the baby as she referred to
Olivia speak
she thought the nine-year-old maybe said
mum that's when I turned round and I
spotted her sat at the bottom of the
stairs I lent over her and like held her
to the left I just huddled over they
tried to get Olivia up the stairs I
couldn't keep her awake I realized that
she must have been hit because I didn't
know until then and I lifted her top up
and the bullet had got her right in the
middle of the chest she added I knew
she'd gone I knew she'd gone
Thomas Cashman appeared to wipe away
tears in the dock the prosecutions say
he was the gunman that night engaged in
a ruthless pursuit of his intended
target a Pursuit that ended with
Olivia's tragic death in her own home he
denies all the charges the court heard
statements from Neighbors of the family
describing what they saw that night one
who said she saw Cheryl Corbell after
the shooting and had never seen anyone
in such a state of distress Greg Milam
Sky News Manchester
large swathes of northern England
Northern Ireland and Scotland are under
severe weather warnings this evening
with forecasters warning of heavy snow
showers of up to 40 centimeters the cold
weather is expected to continue until
the weekend as Katarina batotsu reports
they warned of snow
the UK inches fell in hours cloaking
high hills in the Yorkshire Dales
making morning commutes dangerous here
in Sheffield residence woke up to snow
that continued to get heavier throughout
the day schools across the city have
been shut and there have been warnings
that treacherous conditions could
continue until tomorrow
walking wasn't easy driving even harder
gritters have been out in force as the
Met Office warned of atrocious travel
conditions
many years ago but now
early and they're looking at obviously
looking at the weather forecast for once
National highways closed roads in the
north of England were an amber alert has
been in place electricity companies here
also warned of power Cuts businesses
like this Sheffield Cafe saw slower
trade as customers stayed home with
hospitality it does have a huge impact
definitely just just due to trade you
know you won't see many people walking
around and it's just it's harder for
people to get get out especially in
somewhere like Sheffield where it's so
hilly places are essentially cut off
when it's like this
as more snow fell warnings spread
into North Wales
and Ireland
Birmingham Airport delayed some flights
whilst runways were de-iced brushed and
plowed
but amidst A disruption
for some the weather brought moments of
joy
even a little bit of wonder
I'm from Indonesia so
it is not have a snow in Indonesia is
this the first time you've ever made a
Snowman in your whole life yeah this is
my first time
more spring-like weather is not too far
away the worst of this cold blast is
forecasted to clear by Friday afternoon
Sky News
let's return to the developing story in
Hamburg in Germany where several people
have been killed and others injured in a
church in the German City our New York
correspondent Siobhan Robbins is in
Berlin um have you got any further
updates for us Siobhan
yes so we're getting a little bit more
information we can show you some
pictures from the scene now we
understand that one or more unknown
perpetrators started shooting at people
at a church in Hamburg at the ulsterdorf
District of Hamburg
this evening we know from police
information that several people have
been shot some of them potentially
fatally others have been seriously
injured and there is a large contingent
of police on the scene now we have been
getting some information as well from
DPA news agency here in Germany which
says rescue workers carry people out of
the Jehovah's Witness building
saying that the background the motive
behind the shooting is still unclear but
clearly a very active scene at the
moment lots of Special Forces on the
scene as they try to bring out the
people who have been injured and find
out why this has happened
okay Siobhan thank you for that update
we'll return to that story as soon as we
get further information and
clarification on the numbers of those
who have been fatally shot thank you
to Ukraine now after the head of the
world's nuclear regulator said he was
astonished at International complacency
after yet another power outage at
Europe's biggest nuclear plant in
zapparesia
it's not known if the damage was caused
by the wave of Russian missile strikes
across Ukraine military leaders in cave
say they believe six Hypersonic missiles
were used to Target several towns and
cities killing more than six people our
chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
reports from Kiev
please search for fragments of the
missile that hit this residential
neighborhood in Kiev
they want to know exactly what it was
the Russians fired a whole range of
weapons across the country shattering
the morning piece with devastating
effect
cars caught fire as the missile crashed
into the ground
the car park they surveyed the damaged
vehicle seen what they could repair
I wondered if they're getting used to
all of this hope for the best but the
war goes on right for sure all the words
in the history there
wants to roll there over so I hope it's
gonna be fast and come the peace come
soon
Council workers began delivering rolls
of plastic sheeting for people to repair
their Windows as best as possible it's
relatively mild at the moment but the
temperature here can plummet in a matter
of hours
there has been a break at these times of
incidents have been happening across
Ukraine for months now as civilian
population had I'm getting used to it at
all they live in constant fear that
they're sort of completely inoculous
residential area could be the next one
to get hit
Larissa took me into her apartment she
told me she thought her balcony was
going to fall off as she was shaken by
the explosion I asked her what she
thought of Russia and the war yes
this was a massive Russian attack on
Ukraine's energy infrastructure
a power station in Keith burn through
the morning after a direct hit
by afternoon the fire was out but there
have been widespread power Cuts caused
by the attack
crucially and potentially
catastrophically the Zappa Richie
nuclear power plant was temporarily cut
from The Grid that's for the sixth time
listing this response from the nuclear
watchdog
we are rolling a dice
and if we allow these to continue time
after time then one day our luck will
run out
Sirens periodically sounded throughout
the day
after three weeks of quiet residents
once again returned to the safety of the
metro to await the all clear
it's part of life now
working from the underground
Stu Ramsey Sky News Keith
a gunman opened fire on a crowded Street
in the Israeli city of Tel Aviv this
evening injuring three people before he
was shot and killed medical workers said
one of the Wounded was in a critical
condition the Palestinian group Hammer
said the gunman was one of its members
it said the shooting was in response to
the killing of three members of the
Islamic Jihad Group by Israeli security
forces in a gun battle in the West Bank
the astrologer Mystic Meg whose real
name was Margaret lake has died at the
age of 80. She Wrote horoscopes for the
Sun and News of the World newspapers for
more than 20 years she began her career
working as a sub-editor on the Sunday
paper
NHS prescription charges Will Rise by 30
Pence to 9 pounds 65 from April the 1st
the Department of Health said it had
applied an inflation rate of 3.2 percent
has been revealed as the UK's entrant
for this year's Eurovision song contest
the 25 year old has previously supported
Little Mix on tour and will perform her
track I wrote her song in Liverpool in
May
it's one of the biggest nights in
Showbiz and this Sunday's Oscars will be
the last ceremony before new standards
to boost diversity are introduced but
Sky News analysis suggests they may have
little effect and the president Academy
insists all the best picture nominees
going back several years would have
complied with the new guidelines now one
overlooked director thanks Hollywood
should look to the UK's baftas for an
example of how to affect real change
here's our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer a warning
her report does contain flash
photography
as they roll out the red carpet for
Hollywood's great and good to Grace this
Sunday the academy Keen to hammer home
that after years of Oscar's so white
headlines who ends up here is changing
as next year it's much hyped new rules
kick in designed to improve diversity
with so many workarounds the qualifying
criteria even a film like All Quiet on
the Western Front top heavy with white
male Stars would still have little to
worry about
in fact in an exclusive interview with
Sky News the academy president revealed
all previous Best Picture nominees would
in fact still qualify we did find that
given these new guidelines all the past
nominations would have still qualified
but it was almost a way for people to
just be a little bit more conscious
about those things
while Asian actors have received an
historic high of four nominations this
year there's zero women up for best
director
[Music]
and only two black actors nominated
seemingly overlooked by the academy
for the nominal performances by both
Danielle deadweiler and Viola Davis
there was a lot of female artists and
artists of color working on our film we
want to be acknowledged for our skill
for our Excellence for our craft these
are people who've been out there for
years decades doing what they do
um and not getting noticed for the
female director behind the woman King
absent from this year's all-male lineup
something needs to give it's about a
systemic issue that's been there again
I'm really hoping that the Oscars take a
look at what bafta has done because the
changes have really worked and I think
that's what we need to do while actors
just want to see the best work get
employed it shouldn't just be about no
one's um Heritage or skin color but the
work also speaks for itself which
definitely raises some legit and genuine
questions thank you for all coming out
while the new rules might be
well-intentioned it seems there's a lot
more work to be done if Hollywood is
ever to make real strides forward with
equality cater Spencer Sky News in
Hollywood